Why is it so scary?
Welcome to Doom 64.
Which I think I'm like, there's like no place for me to be.
I have to create my own Doom guy head.
In the middle of the screen.
You feeling better, man?
Actually, I'm feeling like absolute doo-doo today.
I'm feeling quite bad.
But that's okay.
We'll see how far we can get before I'm like, I can't go any
longer.
So, no worries.
Interesting choice of words.
What, do you want me to say?
I feel like, shit.
There.
But yeah, playing Doom 64, long, long, long, long time ago I
played Doom 1.
Those VODs are privated though, sorry.
And we wisps are into doo-doo and stuff.
I don't, don't say that.
Don't say that.
What do you mean?
And, um, I have played Doom 2 before, so I was just like, I
could go into Doom 3, or before Doom 3, I could play Doom
64!
Right?
So, hmm.
Hmm.
He does not speak for me.
Sure.
Sure, I get it.
I get it.
Who's we?
Hello, Mint Fandom.
Hello, he speaks only for himself.
If you're feeling due to today, then you might want to take
your feet out from there.
Huh?
Might want to take your feet out from there.
Hope you feel better soon, though.
Thank you.
Choo!
Membership.
Minto out of tax.
Stop!
There's no out of tax.
But thank you.
Can't wait to hear the screen.
yeah when I was six I rented this at the store got scared by
a pinky and my mom wouldn't let me get rated M games anymore
get revenge for me mint I will I'll get revenge for you
let's see this is already so spooky right and Draco thanks
for the 10 gifted dogs drinks thanks for the 10 gifted thank
you guys so much but yeah I I don't feel so well today so
take it easy on me we're gonna take it easy a little bit as
well I still I'm recovering from the big C and jet lag all
at the same time my mom was just like hey can I can like I
want to meet up but she wanted me to test again before I met
up with her notorious snakes are the gifted and I I tested
two days ago when I was negative but I think it was a false
negative because I tested again two times this morning.
I had COVID still.
Wee!
So I was like, no way!
It's okay though.
The big C is what Kiara is serving.
Absolutely.
But, um, I feel okay for the most part.
just uh just sometimes my head i had a really really really
bad migraine yesterday so it's a good thing i didn't stream
but um uh sometimes i get a little dizzy and sometimes i
feel like i'm gonna throw up a little bit and and my nose is
a little stuff but other than that i'm all good so my dad
played this as a child but i was always too scared to play
myself too i hope you get well soon i missed you lots thank
you you know this this feels like a game my dad today's
father's day isn't it this feels like a game my dad would
have liked but my dad was really into um diablo and never
winter nights um and i remember gifting him oh gosh there
was like it was made by this diablo people i can't remember
the name of it though but yeah if you celebrate father's day
happy father's day um I can be your dad too.
Oh, torchlight!
Yes, yes, yes.
Torchlight, torchlight, torchlight.
Yeah, my dad, he also played, um, there were some, I don't
think it was Call of Duty, but there was some, like, FPS
stuff that he did, but he never, I never saw him play Doom.
Not that I can remember.
Hmm.
And he liked, um, Age of Empires and stuff like that.
One of my favorite Doom-like games are Turok games.
Maybe in the future for a fellow.
game especially to have fun and hope you feel better thank
you yeah i saw some people in the pre-chat asking about like
quake and stuff like that um totally not off the table just
eventually whenever i get to it whenever i feel like it hi
dad hello son and or daughter hello child Hello, my spawn.
Anyway, new game.
Happy Father's Day, Daddy.
Be gentle.
Bring it on.
I own doom.
Watch me die.
What are these?
Dahl, thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Thank you.
Don't call them spawn.
Oh, sorry.
Thanks for spawning me.
Oh, yeah.
It's like instead of where are we dropping?
Well, all kids dropped out of somewhere.
Lost in the story.
Thanks for the tag, Gifter.
Thank you.
So bring it on.
Would that be normal?
Or I own Doom.
Is that one normal?
What'd you do?
Doom mods?
Oh, I'm not opposed to it.
Time to die.
It's hard mode.
I own Doom as normal.
Bring it on seems like normal.
Okay, we'll do bring it on.
Just like the movie.
Bring it on as normal.
Oh.
Armor.
Oh, it's already so spooky.
Why does that look like a trap right there?
What's the music?
I'm scared.
I'm the gun.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Maybe I should move myself.
Where can I go?
I'll move right here.
That way you can still see stuff.
But I'm still a little doom guy head.
Someone got to come out of there.
Beep, boop.
I don't want to shoot just to shoot, but I know if I go down
here.
Oh, I already got the shotgun.
Okay, I thought it was gonna be a trap for sure.
Oh, oh, oh, you see that right there?
Oh!
That's probably one of my friends.
Not
my friends.
Oh, this is just health.
Why is it so scary?
Shoots the friend instantly.
Hold on, one second, I gotta fix my screen, there we go.
One of the big things that separates this from lots of
classic doom is the soundtrack being more horror than heavy
metal it's very atmospheric i'm already getting that vibe is
this a door no friends oh
what's this is this a door i'm guessing space is to open
doors right just like before wait how do i actually open the
doors Sorry, I did not set up for a stream at all.
Thanks for being our dad, of course!
Oh!
No, no, no, no, no.
E!
Ah, e!
Okay, so let me go back to this.
Ah!
This is actually so spooky.
What is this?
Oh, box a bullet's nice.
I'll take that.
Yeah.
Oh my god!
Whoa, it's moving.
I even move with it.
That's so fun.
Oh, I'm moving.
Wow!
That's so cool.
Um, I can't get your bullets.
Nice.
What is...
Do you think I need to do anything with this?
Oh my gosh, it really did work!
Oh, wow!
I think I'm a genius.
Oh.
I gotta change!
Oh!
Wait, there was other stuff.
No, these are just lights.
Okay, well, oh, look at my fist.
We'll go back to the Oh, never mind I cannot go back to the
shotgun Okay, that's a little sad That's fine though
I'll pack a chainsaw I'll skin your ass raw
Oh, oh, I'll pack
a...
Well, they're much pinker in this game No!
Shotgun is three.
Oh, thank you.
Not that I don't mind the chainsaw, but the sound of it is a
little much, you know?
Oh, there's the blue key.
Okay, nice.
Oh!
Oh, yeah!
Holy cow!
I have reflexes like a cat.
I'm picking up stuff first.
Okay, never mind.
E.
Oh.
What is that?
What did I just open?
Uh-oh.
What did I just unleash?
The sky is so beautiful.
Oh, the sky is so beautiful.
Um, okay, let's go.
I don't know what I just unleashed.
I'm scared.
Rheh.
Oh.
Anybody else in here ready for a...
Oh, I hear him.
I hear him.
Somewhere.
Armor.
Give me more armor.
Oh, I hear him!
Oh, come on.
I know I'm shotgunning or I'm sniping with shotgun but you
know whatever.
What is this?
Maybe it's more health.
Smells minty here.
This is so spooky.
Hope that you start feeling better.
I said I get a happy birthday.
Ziz said happy birthday.
Singing's not necessary.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you happy oh my god happy birthday to you
everything's fine probably did those explode okay they do
explode good to know
Freak phantoms about to freak some demons.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, do I have to be fast?
Okay.
I have to be fast.
Wait a second.
Did I go in here?
Is this new?
Ah!
I think it's new.
Uh-oh.
I heard something big.
something powerful yellow room with a pancake gotta go fast
chat is this modded it is oh we're at the very beginning it
is not modded what
does that sound oh there's a lot more pinkies in here than I
thought there would be Oh my god.
They could open the door themselves?
Why are you so intelligent?
That's the BGM.
No way.
Oh.
That was wet.
Oh, yeah.
This is such...
Wow-y!
Armor bonus, baby.
The door squish oh oh gross wait that's nasty oh what is
that oh no wait uh oh wait is that the real exit it says the
exit but hold on hold on hold on there was another area I'm
not quite yet ready.
Yeti.
Ah!
Oh.
Um.
I think I found a hidden...
Nice.
I don't know how I found that.
Ah!
Blueberry!
Wait, where do I get that?
It's showing me.
It's showing me the secret location of a blueberry, but I
don't know how to get it.
Yeah.
What the heck is this game?
There's so much more to explore.
Is it this?
Is this the blueberry?
This must be it.
Bajerk!
Um.
Anyway, nice exploring.
Though...
I don't...
Maybe I guess we just leave.
I do want the blueberry, but...
I guess it's fine.
I don't have to get all the secrets.
And this is kind of easy to get lost here.
I think, maybe.
Where could he be?
Hmm.
You're very close to the Blueberry?
Dang.
Ah!
So close.
Zero secrets.
Password.
Entering the Terraformer.
No Blueberry.
Next time we'll get him.
Shoot him when they're not expecting it.
Oh.
That is an imp, right?
Is that his butthole?
It's gaping.
Wow.
Or that's where...
Maybe that's where I shot him.
No, I think that's his butthole.
Passwords are for area without save.
Hmm.
Do you guys see it?
Or is it just me?
Look, look, look.
Look, look.
He's got a gaping hole.
Can I check these?
What the numbers?
What do they mean?
Oh, I need a yellow key.
Oh, well.
Oh, door.
Oh, oh!
Are you kidding me right now?
Um, there must be another door somewhere else.
Oh.
What's the sound?
Can I go through this hole?
Reminds me of laser tag.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so terrified though.
It's dark.
It's so dark.
Lights.
Oh, thank goodness.
Whoa.
Uh-oh.
I got the mega armor and I...
Unleashed some other people.
Okay, we have several things that have happened here now.
Oh!
Like that.
Need a blue key.
Okay, makes sense.
Blueberry!
Blueberry spotted.
Ah!
This game is so whack!
Uh-oh.
All of these are gonna open, aren't they?
Oh god.
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
Who's snoring?
Oh, what just happened?
My health didn't go down there.
Oh, oh, oh.
That's a different...
That looks like a chain...
Not the chain gunner.
A gun.
Oh, my gosh.
Machine gun over there, maybe.
There's a zombie above me.
If I shoot...
Dummy.
Oh, there's another one.
Oh!
Okay, here we go.
I was prepared.
Oh my god, don't shoot me.
Can I get him?
Come back over here.
Come back over here, Stinky.
I can hear you, I can hear you mouth breathing.
There we go.
That's what I love about Doom.
You barely have to aim.
Oh!
We're back to normal.
Okay.
Oh!
So how do I get to the chain?
I'm...
chainsaw.
Is it four?
Yes.
Okay.
No aim required.
Just a little bit of aim required.
I don't want to say no aim.
Tiny, limited aim required, you know.
What's over here?
Have I gone in?
No, I have not gone in.
Oh, there's the blue key.
It looks like a trap.
Looks like a trap to me.
It looks like... Look at that.
They give you literally everything you need.
They're like, you need more armor.
You need more ammo.
You need everything.
You sad, sad.
We'll come back in here.
Hold on.
Oh, gosh.
Where's the blue room?
Okay, this is...
Okay, okay, okay.
I know where we are.
So here...
It's the blue berry.
Is this a staircase?
Yeah.
What is this?
Goggles?
Light amplification goggles.
Oh, okay.
I'll take that.
Okay.
The blueberry is right there, you guys.
Taunting me.
Look at that!
No, the mood lighting.
Oh, sorry.
Wow.
This game looks so crazy.
Oh, shoot.
I went berserk again.
I went berserk mode.
Hmm.
Here!
Punch the wall, punch the wall, punch the wall, punch the
wall, punch the wall.
Punch the wall.
Red key.
I could have told you that.
The punches are so funny.
I know, right?
Interesting.
Oh, the mood lighting really did just...
Oh, this is the blue key.
That's right.
Which is over in here.
Alright, let's go into this trap.
Let's fall for it like the suckers we are, little saps.
What the?
Wait.
Wait!
Oh.
There's puzzles in this game now, too?
I'm too small.
Please, I don't know how to lift my arms.
Uh-oh.
Wait, those just lifted up, didn't they?
Those were not lifted up before.
Interesting.
I don't think it's teleporting again.
Short ghost problems.
Absolutely.
Now we must choose.
Oh no, my goggles!
What was the point of grabbing them?
We have four choices.
How spooky.
Four is my favorite number.
Hmm.
Doom Guy Short King confirmed.
We love that for him.
Choose wisely.
This one is the only one without computer.
This one...
Is that...
Yeah, three is the least suspicious, right?
Sharks.
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Oh, nice.
Oh.
Run!
Oh,
how can I make it faster?
Shift to run.
There is no shift to run.
Hit cap slot.
Oh, whoa!
Capsula... Oh, no, I hit Tab.
Oh my goodness.
Oh!
I didn't realize I was walking this whole time.
Why can he go even faster?
Ah!
Don't sneak up on me like that.
Look!
It's... Come on.
Look at that hole.
So...
Holy cow.
Wait.
But space doesn't make me run either.
So I just have to auto run or something, right?
I'm telling you!
I told you I saw it the whole time.
That's not for me shooting.
I think they're a little freaky up in here.
It's a little freaky here in hell.
all I'm saying.
Okay, we gotta run through this, right?
Okay.
Now I know how to run.
Ah!
Ha!
Has some weird controls because it came from the N64.
Yeah, yeah.
No worries.
So far, it's not so bad, I'd say.
Oh my goodness.
Whoa!
Rockets!
What do we need those for?
Uh oh.
Whoa, invisible pinky!
Sounds like my cat snoring.
This is a door.
That was not it.
Ah!
Ha!
We got the blueberry!
Yummy,
yummy!
This is definitely a door though.
This is 100% a door.
Thank you!
I think you're a little freaky.
Can't open it from that side.
Dang.
Okay, well, we also had down here.
Oh gosh, the music makes me so afraid.
The music makes me so scared.
Is this a teleporter?
Oh, oh my god.
Oh, whoa!
Ah!
Oh my god.
Wait!
I think I peed myself.
From the very beginning, y'all.
No, I lost all my weapons.
And I lost everything.
Also, it looks way darker in OBS than I realized.
It looks...
It looks way darker in OBS than...
Did I kill him?
Not yet.
Oh my goodness.
Die.
Die already.
Ah, man.
No auto saves.
No, I'm not playing through OBS.
I just realized...
I can actually see so much better than I think you guys can.
It's not dark on YouTube?
Oh, okay, that's good.
You can save manually.
I forgot about this door, to be honest.
Oh, man, I have to go through everything again.
And I lost my...
Well, I never really used the chainsaw, so I guess it's
okay.
Oh, I forgot about this room.
Eek!
Body armor.
And then the guy...
Here!
Is there any other guys here?
No.
Grab everything, though.
I don't want to go berserk.
Hmm...
It's appropriately spooky dark.
I'd say so too.
And we know how to get to the blueberry.
It's okay, we lost progress, but...
It wasn't like...
It could be where...
Oh!
Where the hell did you come from?
Ah!
Oh!
Okay.
I am I'm a different ghost now I've learned I've learned
Choo Choo, thank you Okay That's right, this one Battle
hardened It's very dark on Twitch Pure Black even Except for
some white text that says offline.
What?
Offline.
They're...
They're, uh, they're silencing me.
Where does... Oh, wait, it's not going in the same order.
Wait, am I crazy?
Maybe it is going in the same order.
Why?
Is this different now, too?
Wait, is this It's different now also?
No way.
Huh?
I'm being oppressed.
But it's...
this one then.
Oh, shoot.
Where did you come from?
Okay, cool.
Okay.
Blue door Blue door leads to blueberry Blueberry leads to
death
Okay Caps lock Okay we've been running Oh
Whoa that was close Ah And
there's two more here
And invisible pinky here
oh my god oh that was close
I'll turn an auto run off for now because it stresses me out
a little bit it makes me be too fast you know too fast too
furious oh but what do I do about the maybe I just shouldn't
go in that area but I feel like I have to Where do I go?
What do I do, you know?
I don't want to go in here!
Otherwise I need...
Hmm.
Can you save?
Oh, I can!
Save.
Bring it on!
How many levels are in this game, by the way?
I'm just curious.
When I play these games nowadays, I'm like, is wrong with
the devs making it so hard meanwhile my goofy ass young back
then a little easy
about 25 over 30.
there was like a teleporter over here maybe we should just
wait no over here maybe we should just take it
right this one right here run i'm running oh oh i'm back at
the beginning oh okay Hmm.
I never, I didn't get a key or anything like that, so it's
kind of...
This is a red key, right?
Yeah.
This version also comes with a new episode.
No way, really?
Went down there.
I don't have a yellow key to go in there, so I need keys.
blue key.
It's not any of this, right?
Ow!
Okay.
Thanks, game.
You're so funny.
Okay, game.
It has to be in here.
Oh, shucks.
I think once I...
It's this that started, isn't it?
I think.
Okay.
Ah!
Oh, whoopsie.
I think it's that.
I tripped that and it all starts coming down.
Stalling pro.
What are you talking about?
I'm just trying to figure out a strategy.
Fine, I'm gonna go.
I made it.
Oh, oh, oh.
Shop, shop, shop.
Try and hurt me, stupid imp.
I'll blast you to pieces.
Am I good?
Ah!
Oh my god, I'm not good.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
That was it.
Red key acquired.
Oh, outwards.
Okay.
I don't like the music.
It scares me.
Okay.
Whereup?
Ah!
What the hell?
Why didn't I kill you?
I was standing right there.
I should have one-shotted you.
Gaping hole.
Come here.
What's going on?
Ah!
Huh?
What?
I can't leave here.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Hydraulic press versus made me.
Oh, now I can go.
Okay.
What?
Are you gonna go down again?
No?
We're safe?
Maybe?
Safe is not maybe the best word.
We're...
Oh, I see you.
I see you down there.
messed up.
Is he still there?
I don't think I can get him from here.
That's okay.
Okay, let's just go.
Ah!
Where are you?
Look at them, they're in their little cages.
But someone got free.
Okay.
You're stuck in there, and I'm not.
This is so freaky.
Why do they have guns in jail?
That's a great question actually.
That's actually a really good question to ask.
Oh, the grand...
Oh, I thought he was just gonna slide on down.
I got a shotgun.
Hey.
Oh my goodness.
Oh goodness.
From every angle!
Come on!
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
Taking out everybody one by one.
Surely but surely, this guy too.
There we go.
Nice.
Dune 64 fan here.
Hello!
Alright, let's go up here.
Any computers gonna tell me any secrets?
Ugh.
This game is old.
I mean, it God is old.
He's for the N64.
Like...
Oh!
Goodness gracious.
Hey!
Oh!
Two at once, baby!
Double kill.
I'm too good.
I'm too powerful.
They can't stop.
Probably.
Any secrets?
Yeah.
Okay, I put this down and it's gonna...
Am I running?
Okay, I'm running.
Secrets.
Remember to save Minto!
A key!
Yes.
I turned that, so if I go back here...
The key?
Okay!
I think we can get that.
heck you out of here oh secret area i got a box of rocket
what do i need what what do i need those for what do i need
those for any other secrets secret area nice job thank you
thank you it's my intuition
oh this is the other side.
Isn't this...
Why does this feel longer than like going back this way?
Doesn't really feel like a shortcut.
I'd say.
Are you okay?
Even going down the stairs?
Oh, wait.
We can't get back up.
Just kidding.
Yeah, it's old.
N64.
Matt Damon, aging gift.
Okay.
way.
What does that sound?
Sounds like the spider demon.
I think it's just doors closing, but it sounds suspicious,
you know.
Everything in this game seems suspicious to me.
Wait, how do we get over there?
Right through here!
Oh!
I didn't I didn't realize that was the exit.
Yippee!
Only 66 items!
And 50% secrets.
Would love to see Half-Life someday.
Maybe.
I got the password.
Do these passwords change?
Or are they like, I mean, like, should I be saving them or
are they written down somewhere?
Remember we're playing this game on my brother's 1994 Mac
computer.
Holy cow.
Write down the first password.
I think I have it.
I think I screen-shotted it.
One second.
Yeah, I screen-shotted the first one.
The password is only if you're not saving.
Ah!
Okay, then it doesn't really matter.
Also, I'm going to do this real quick.
I was going to keep myself in a little box.
I mean, I'm still kind of in a little box, but I got a
little bit more wiggle room now.
Okay.
Oh.
You guys are right behind me.
I was like, what's going...
What's attacking me?
shot nightmare imps not to be confused with them you know
normal ass imps which are not hellish and nightmare ish
enough I suppose oh yeah hmm I'm glad oh my this!
He actually got me.
I don't even hear them in there.
Whoa!
Wait, does this one go down?
Oh, it already went down too.
Cool!
Where shall we go?
I guess this...
Did I miss my chance?
Um...
I think it was better that I waited.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Quit your whining.
I want to go down here.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, we got the chain gun!
In 64, we used to have a safe pack like PS1.
PS1's safe cards.
I think the passwords is in case you didn't have one of
those.
Very thoughtful of the devs.
Oh, that's so sweet.
Um, let's go down.
Piyop!
Pick up all this stuff.
Oh, nice.
Let's go back to the other side.
Piyop!
Pick up everything.
I think we're done in here.
So anyway, I started blasting.
Backpack!
So backpack allow us to...
to hold more stuff.
He turned it to spaghetti!
Coco, David!
Why are there more of you?
Why do you have chance?
You little freak?
They don't look so...
They don't look like I remember.
They don't look quite like I remember.
Okay, interesting.
We got two teleporters here.
Oh, secret.
No!
Secret.
Dang.
juicy.
Super shotgun double barrel shotguns are my favorite guns to
get in old-school inspired shooters.
Also hymen.
Hello!
Hello, hello.
Okay, I guess we'll go through... well now we know that
these guys are about... oh it just leads us to upper level.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Let me help please.
Oh.
Okay, so I think both of them are the same, right?
Who's in there?
Oh, no!
What are these guys called again?
Oh, um...
Oh, not Revenant's...
Lost Souls!
Lost Souls, Lost Souls.
How do I get down?
oh wait right here oh do i need to do i need to run into it
no revenants in here wait in this game or
oh wait there we go yellow key did we see a yellow door i
don't think i saw one did i i might just blind?
I don't remember seeing a yellow door.
Do you guys?
The very star.
Was this not the very star?
Blue key area had another door.
Look at this one.
This seems quite yellow.
Back to the blue key room.
Okay, let me go back.
Oh, I thought you meant like that, as in, you know, the room
that we used.
Oh my god, again?
Why are you respawned?
Oh, rocket launcher!
Oh, this door.
I see it.
I don't even notice it.
Thanks, guys.
Huh.
It's a lot of armor and a lot of health.
Wait, which button is...
Okay, five.
Four.
A three.
Happy Father's Day, Myth.
Happy Father's Day.
Since I...
I don't have a dad.
Can you guys be my dad?
Okay, let me...
Oh, my goodness.
Lasso's!
Easy peasy.
Yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy.
Stop playing game and clean your room.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, hi, pies.
She's in here with me.
She might want out, though.
Okay, I guess we just go down.
What did that open?
Ooh.
Box of rockets.
Let me out.
Oh.
What was that over there?
Oh, I saw that open up.
I saw right here it opened up.
Oh.
Can I do it again?
Eh?
Must have been the wind.
If I go...
Wait, eh?
I'm so confused right now.
Try going in the door.
Run, run, run, run, run.
Run!
Ah!
No, the little thing that would let me go inside, it
disappeared too quickly.
Okay, hold on.
Raaat!
Hmm.
Am I running?
I am.
Okay.
I gotta be so speedy though.
Also, what is...
I guess that one's already active.
Oh, oh!
Oh!
Oh, what the?
I'm so confused.
There is no jump in this game.
There's no jump in doom.
Come on!
Ah!
I got it!
Secret Ariel!
A blast in his eyes.
Nice!
We got it.
But, actually, I do need a red key, don't I?
I do actually need a red key.
Where do I get that from?
Hmm.
This one's already activated.
This one only opens this door.
Hmm.
Right?
Blue key room again.
Oh!
Who keeps placing stuff here?
Okay.
Who keeps putting stuff in there?
Exit already?
Yippee!
Very though.
That's okay.
I'm not gonna get all the secrets.
Oh my god.
Only 20% of secrets though.
That's pretty...
That's pretty crazy.
Um...
One second.
Holding area.
Do you guys...
Do you... Be honest with me though, are you able to see
alright and everything?
Because I can turn up the brightness if you guys need it.
Hand holding area.
four levels were big on what on shifting little bits around
and changing the layout slash adding items that weren't
there before that's so cool because it makes you want to
explore even more
are all the um same monsters and stuff from you know doing
prior in this as well or is there any new guys or anyone
missing oh thank you Papa Hepabon no no there's a few
missing who's missing please tell me it's the the jockey
schools they're the ones I hate the most oh wait why am I
picking He's up, it's not doing anything.
Chain gunner.
No chain gunner for real?
I was wondering where those guys were.
To be honest.
Is that a berserk thing?
How do I get to it?
Wait, actually I don't...
Oh.
Secret.
Okay.
No skeleton boys, if that helps.
Flashing lights warning soon.
Oh, thank you.
Libby Cor, thanks for the gift.
Did?
Why is the blueberry just right there?
Oh.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
Thank you for the warning.
Flashing.
Flashing lights.
Oh, jeez.
Oh, God.
Oh, it was such a bait.
Oh, my God.
Turn it off.
Oh, hello, imp.
Oh, hello, imps.
Imp.
party!
What's in here?
Oh.
How do I get that?
Oh my goodness.
It's over now.
Thank goodness.
That was pretty...
Regular imps.
Um, so no chain gunners.
Um, wait.
Barons were the, um...
Where are the, uh, what's the words?
I want that.
There are barons of hell here, yes.
Okay, okay, okay.
Barons are in this game.
But those are not the skelly guys.
Those are like the big guys that look like, um, that look
like, you know, like a stereotypical demon.
Okay, this seems like I'm activating a maze of some sort.
Like I'm lifting walls and moving some things around.
Or maybe not.
Maybe I should just activate all of them.
I'm not quite sure actually.
I don't know what's going on.
The big goatman.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hmm.
Oh.
How do I get...
He's floating in this guy.
He's floating.
Knights and barons, aka bigger imps.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, what's this?
Oh!
Oh my goodness.
Hello.
It just flew me off.
I didn't even mean to come down here.
Are there, are there, uh, are there, um, are there, um, are
there meatball guys?
I can't remember what they're called either.
The uglier Coco demons.
How do I get up?
Didn't just like that?
There we go.
Pain Elementals!
Yes.
So I really only remember Pinky.
Pinky...
Where was the blue door?
I don't think I remember seeing it.
Uh...
What's this door?
Oh!
Woo!
I know he could get me from up there.
I could get him...
Two!
I thought I heard another guy.
Imagining it, perhaps.
The super shotgun uses two, right?
We can shoot one that switches.
Oh, oh, I can shoot that one.
Oh.
I didn't know if it would be a waste.
Oh, that's fun.
And I activated something.
Wait, oh.
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, oh.
Now I'm in the zoo.
Yeah, I discovered, I realized what it did, like, as soon as
I did it, silly me.
It's okay, though.
God,
where did you come from?
Good lord.
Goodness gracious, sir.
Scared that heck out of me.
It's just a skelly, man.
How do we get that other...
Oh.
Hey, buddy.
Alright, we got lots of switches around here in this game.
Oh, no!
It's these guys!
Ow, the goats, the goats, the goats!
Oh, my goodness.
They're strong.
Uh, four.
Bye!
Oh, goats, the goats.
Anyway.
Oh, nope, another person.
Don't forget your rocket launcher.
Oh, you're right.
You have that.
Is this real?
Chat, this is real.
I'm not quite done yet.
Oh, ow!
God, I wish I were done.
There was one more.
At least.
Interesting.
Do I run across those?
But how do I get up there?
Secret.
Oh, blueberry!
I'm a bit of a genius.
Ah!
I got it!
Yippee!
Ten-sai.
Oh,
so I can't get over there now, though.
You have to...
Oh, okay.
Someone was saying that I can't get to that secret area
because I guessed wrong.
Aw, man.
Well, I got this secret area, at least.
By punching a wall.
It failed the puzzle.
How was I supposed to know?
Oh well
Yippee 95 Profile Thanks for the 10 gifts
I got some Oh Some edamame from Basically before I left
Japan Because I couldn't do anything On my last day, right
before I left, I went to Don Quixote, and I went to a couple
of, like, um, Conveni, and I was like, I'm just buying all
the snacks.
I couldn't buy anything else.
My suitcases were so empty, so I just bought a bunch of
snacks.
And now I'm eating them.
And these ones are really good.
I've never had these edamame ones, but I thought they would
be, like, the bean part.
But they're actually quite, um, they're quite fluffy.
Of course I got jelly.
Oh wow.
It's red, yellow.
Let's save.
Get on.
I almost feel like maybe I should have gone harder.
Okay.
Well, that's okay.
It's been a while since I've played Doom, so...
It's fine if I'm, you know, on a little bit of an easier
level, I suppose.
Oh, um...
Hmm.
Gets a bit nastier later.
I believe you.
Blue?
Um...
Is this the door?
Oh, yes it is.
Absolutely!
Yeah, you tried.
You tried.
This one?
No?
How do I get you?
Just reach out and grab it, Doomguy.
Use your arms!
You have... I clearly have some!
Hold on.
I'll punch the yellow key.
I love not having to aim in these.
I know, right?
It's such like a...
Wow, look at...
What the chandelier is so fancy in there.
My baby arms.
Okay.
What is it?
Oh my goodness!
It's a party.
Bye.
Okay, so yellow key in here.
Whatever the hell that is in there.
I think there was a door.
Oh, we haven't gone down here yet.
Oh, lost souls.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
The last souls look cooler in this game, actually.
They look quite neat.
I like them.
I'm grabbing health and it's not doing anything.
But I can grab more armor.
That's always a thing.
Okay.
I don't see a switch.
Paint Elementals do too.
Okay.
I'm looking...
Because those guys look goofy as hell in the original.
Paint Elementals look...
It looks so dumb.
It's really funny watching...
What's the word?
Yippee!
It's really funny seeing Doom Eternal and stuff because I
don't recognize.
I'm like, wait, that's so-and-so?
I'm like, wait, that's a pinky?
Oh my goodness.
Ouch!
I got caught by just a grunt.
Be careful who you make fun of in middle school.
It's like that for Doom 3.
Just goofy, the goofy looking idiots.
Oh my goodness!
Oh my god.
Why these guys are doing the most damage to me?
It's a little frustrating.
him.
Are there any secrets here?
Secret.
I'm hacking.
Um...
.
Sometimes I really try to get me.
Okay, that just goes back down, I suppose.
Imp.
Hmm.
Hacking.
Dan!
Thank you so much for the 20 gift.
Thank you!
I'm running.
Ah!
Uh, I got a shot.
good oh super shot i already had that though that's okay
thank you for the meal
oh yeah oh this is what happens when i click this
and then in here was a whole lot of nothing
okay Okay, let's head back.
This room was also empty.
That I know of.
There was a door up top.
There was?
Was I blind?
Up here?
Oh!
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
Sometimes I can be a little blind.
Now what did that open?
Here's the question.
What did it open?
To be fair, the doors are very similar colors.
Sometimes I'm just not looking for it, you know, so...
Maybe.
I'll get better about it, I think, eventually.
Maybe in here?
No?
Down in here?
No.
And in here?
And...
Here?
Something changed?
You?
Yellow key!
Whoa!
It's dark!
Armageddon.
Yeah, welcome back.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you.
Or welcome.
Blueberry.
Oh, that door's a little bit of aggressive.
Like the wriggling flesh mounds are just a little, a little
gross.
Doom guy too thick.
Doom guy.
These are these bars are like 10 feet apart.
We're just we're just that we're just that thick man.
Um what did that open?
Oh blueberry blueberry blueberry secrets secrets secrets
Hmm What did it open?
We went down here before right What's in here?
Nothing.
Have we gone here?
Yes.
What?
I don't recognize these walls at all.
That's some dude named David Hader yesterday.
He was talking about you!
No, he wasn't.
Stop it.
Is this new?
No.
Where do I go?
I can't.
never tell what where something will activate i could never
tell
he is a wisp
like press the button and it activated what map I hate I'll
be honest I hate the map in Doom Because What does this even
mean first of all But second of all I hate that If I'm
checking other places on the map I have to move with the map
Like Like for instance If I'm just like Oh what's this Like
I'm now here You know I don't like that You can zoom out
with Q and R Oh
I do like though that it's um that it is kind of like oh
let's check that area it is kind of um it's colored based on
the yes there we go based on the um the room Ooh, that was
loud.
Because it helps a lot, actually.
Uh-oh.
Another.
Another maze.
Um.
But that does help me.
I don't want to go berserk.
I'm not ready to go berserk.
Boo, boo, boo.
I'll take that.
Ouch!
Oh,
this is not real.
This sure is a maze-y maze.
Yes, indeed.
Oh, wait, it turned around.
Bozo.
Oh, come on.
That's totally something.
We're activating so much stuff.
Real fake doors.
Okay.
Uh, shoot.
Wait, no.
Oh!
That's why.
Ah!
These are gonna be...
I was gonna say these will be the end of me, but they have
already been the end of me.
And they sound so squishy.
Every time.
I remember there was a secret.
I don't want to test everything, every single one, though.
But sometimes these walls open up.
Oh my god.
No, no, no, please!
I was walking!
I got stuck on the wall!
No!
Hmm.
Squish ASMR.
Where am I?
Ah, I know where we are.
Actually that's so funny.
I know because of this cornerling.
Yes, okay.
Where?
Ah!
Oh my god.
Crushers equal minty ectoplasm.
Yeah, I remember because I tried that light.
Uh, here?
Is this open now?
Is this all fine and dandy?
Oh, oops.
Meatball.
No, that's not the meatball yet even.
We haven't even reached full meatball.
Don't worry, we'll get there.
How do I get the blueberry?
Somehow.
Look at this odd.
Oh my god, it's so gross.
It's so nasty.
Oh.
Let's see them.
And the blue key is in there.
Oh my goodness.
Are you kidding me right now?
Um, wait, I can stand inside, can't I?
Oh.
Oh, there's nothing in here though.
Yeah, come at me.
Try again.
Stupid lost souls.
Well done.
Thank you!
Welcome back from Apkai, your summer podcast episodes have
been keeping me sane the past few weeks of finance work.
Thank you!
Thank you for listening!
I'm so happy!
Thank you!
What did I pick up?
The blue key!
Oh!
There's a soft, a soft mumble in my ear.
I heard it.
Imp ASMR.
Yeah, that's exactly what it was.
I saw this one.
This screen.
These screens must tell me the truth of the blueberry.
I'll never know Hmm.
I wonder if I can blow some of them up.
If that will do anything.
I'm going to test all these.
Now that I know sometimes they'll tell me things, I have to
always...
Oh.
What's that?
Hmm?
Oh, I hear another growl.
Oh?
What did that do?
It turned on and off immediately.
Hmm.
Doom Shoddy's always hit so good.
I know, right?
You can even snipe with them, basically.
It's great.
I can still hear it in here.
Hmm.
Okay, well, I guess we'll go through here.
Never mind.
Hello?
Uh-oh.
Need a shotgun emote.
You two might get mad at me for a little bit.
that.
I might be like, um, what do you need that for?
Don't worry about it.
Bubble tea.
Oh my goodness, I wish I could get some bubble tea.
What?
Maybe it works now?
What am I missing here?
was like connecting to it somehow.
That turns off a minute.
It's a time switch.
Yeah, but for what?
Is it timed for this?
Oh!
Ah, I see, I see it, okay.
Oh, that was a cool, that was really fast.
Okay, we're back in business, baby.
Okay, that doesn't open quite yet.
Woo!
Get out of my way.
Who's behind here?
Who's in here?
Uh-oh.
Coco Demon!
Ew.
It's supposed to be a fast-paced game.
I know.
I know that I don't go at the right doom pace, okay?
But I'm a cautious... I'm a cautious ghost.
Can you blame me?
Oh, this is probably...
Now I probably have to go back.
There we go.
Exit!
All about tactical espionage action.
Only 93% kills?
But I got all the secrets.
Interesting.
Makes the game more atmospheric.
I'm not quite...
guy you know that guy goes in and he's just like boom bam
bam boom but for me i'm just like a little baby
oh my god
ew that guy was really gonna come upon me oh shit uh Four.
There we go.
Take him down!
Hell Knight.
Oh, I need a yellow key for this.
Oh, a hero.
Okay.
I heard him grunting over there.
Nasty.
Yeah,
yeah, Mr.
Hi Mint, hello!
Hello, hello!
Actually took quite a bit of my health.
That wasn't so great.
That was not so good.
Ouch!
I hear them.
I hear them from beyond the walls.
Ah!
They're everywhere!
Oh my god, shoot.
Get them all at once!
Oh my god.
Ah!
Oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, the holes in hell, the holes in hell.
There we go.
Oh my god.
this...
Ah!
He's gonna come around the corner any second.
Oh my god!
Opus isn't a waste.
Oh wait, that's just an imp!
Sorry, Mr. Imp.
I kind of took you.
He kind of really overkilled you.
Sorry, Mr. Imp.
Imp evaporated.
Oh my goodness.
Ow!
My god!
They all come from everywhere!
Where?
How do I get back up there?
Up here?
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit.
That imp had a bad day.
I'm having a bad...
They're all ganging up on me like crazy.
Like the...
I feel like the difficulty went from zero to a hundred.
All of a sudden.
There's still more!
I can't even explore the area.
I'm just like...
I'm just a kill... Look at all this!
This is a bloodbath!
I'm just a killing machine!
Wow.
Wait.
This is the one... Which one does this?
Oh, I can't remember.
Just you wait.
Oh, man.
Yeah, I hear you.
I hear...
Actually, I don't remember.
What's the pink one for?
It's so cute.
Ah!
Oopsie.
Oh.
Okay.
Let's go back.
You jerk!
Okay.
Nice.
Woo.
Oh.
Yeah, Loki.
Oh, that was...
There was the one that we couldn't get.
There was like a...
From the main area, there was a little lever that we
couldn't pull.
This area is such a maze, though.
I'm getting so lost.
I'm getting so lost right now.
Did I grab everything in here?
I think so.
Everything that I could.
Yeah, switch back at the beginning.
Yes, yes, yes.
Well, there's a lot of health around here in case we need
it, so.
Oh, this way.
It was up there, right?
I still haven't even gotten up here.
What's in here?
Oh, this is the entrance.
Where I started, I think.
Oh.
Rip Megasphere.
We'll go back.
Wait, this is where I just came from.
See, I'm so lost.
Woo!
It's okay.
Okay.
Oh.
It's timed.
I have to find the secret, though, yeah.
Oh.
Uh.
Ah!
Who was that?
You!
Okay, let's go back and see if we can find the secret.
Oh!
Wait.
It opened up though.
It was just open.
Shinzo, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Cheeky shot.
Oh, maybe I have to do it on the way down?
Ah!
Hmm.
I saw it open, though.
I saw it open.
Oh, goodness.
Go further out of the corridor, then come back.
this way and come back ah thank you
oh dang i really thought i was gonna lead to to the to the
other sphere the not the pearl the non-blue where was that
anyway i can't i can't even oh i found it
I found it!
We'll see if you can find a secret.
I knew where it was all along!
The jawbreaker.
Okay, when this comes down...
Hmm.
How do I get over there?
Eddie of VTubers.
Don't call me that.
Hmm.
Am we missing something?
Perhaps.
I don't think it's a speed thing, because I can't even get
around it until it goes down.
And by the time it goes down, this is already up, right?
Oh.
I like how I sometimes just incidentally run into some of
these things.
Oh, oh, that was close.
We straighted up Doriftoed up across there.
It was kind of crazy.
I don't think I can get that guy.
But I can get that guy.
I'm just stumbling my way through here.
It kind of...
It feels like with Metal Gear how they're just like, oh,
Solid Snake was so good at his job when a lot of the times
he was just like...
He was just kind of like, what's going on?
Ow!
Oh my god!
He's just kind of in the right place.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Right place at the right time.
Come here.
Die already!
I hear the pinky.
I see him.
I see the pinky.
Come here, pinky.
Come here.
Come here, Pinky.
Come over here.
There we go.
Hokey-dokey.
Good stuff.
Pinky...
Oh!
I picked up a box of showers.
Pinky pop a hippo bar.
Box of rockets.
Um...
Open up.
Come on!
Open up!
Give me the stuff!
Press the doom button to doom all over your foes.
Doom!
Nasty.
Oh, uh oh.
Stop!
Oh,
opened up something.
Oh, opened up that area.
Is there another guy in here?
No.
Ah!
Where did you come from?
There's more of them.
Oh, I see what it is.
It's a paid elemental.
Oh, my good.
Look at him from here.
Wait, I kind of want to see him, though.
Whoa, he kind of looks awesome.
Whoa!
It kind of looks awesome, though.
Did I kill him?
I can't tell.
I'm always in the wrong place at the right time.
We know.
Oh.
Hi, Huey.
Huey.
Where am I hearing it from?
Oh!
I think
it's the last one?
Now I can't see nothing.
Hold on, let me, uh, I will turn up the display.
Um.
Oh, well, no, we don't need it any more than that.
Uh, overall brightness.
That's as max as it can go.
I can turn it on environmental brightness.
Maybe that'll be better.
Oh my god.
There's so many in here.
There's so many invisible pinkies in here.
I don't want to go berserk.
How do I get out of here?
Spooky!
Oh!
Stairs on the wall.
How can you guys see better than I can?
This?
How am I supposed to go up it, though?
Oh!
It's like the smallest...
Huh?
Whoa!
How the hell am I doing this?
I think I'm...
Oh, my god, I can kind of see them now.
What the hell?
What are these?
These stairs are for the thinnest person alive.
You know, legs of a mountain go.
Exactly.
What is this, for real?
Actual legs of a mountain goat Okay, hold on, I don't want
to quite do that yet Can't go in there Okay, but there was a
door That door over there No wonder everybody's dead here
Okay, never mind That is not a door This seems to Hmm How do
I get to the blueberry?
Hmm, hmm, hmm, indeed.
Ah!
Good thing there's no fall damage.
It's just...
It's just horribly obnoxious.
Okay, I'm gonna go through this one.
Oh, it took me back to here.
Okay.
Alright.
We running?
Run!
Just run!
I don't know what I did.
It's so bright now.
I can turn it down.
It looks all the same for me.
It truly only looks different in OBS, which is so strange.
Hmm.
Do I go back down there now?
Let's try this one.
Oh, they're both the same.
How do I blueberry?
Well, I don't really need it.
But I kind of just want it.
You know?
Kind of just want it.
Hmm.
Just to have it, you know?
Um, I might drop too.
I'm picking up stuff that I don't need, but that's okay.
Oh, oh, I needed that.
Very nice.
Smallest, thinnest walls in history.
Someone said try running off the side into the room, but
like there's a, there's like, there's no way to get into it.
And then also there's stuff in here.
There's so much stuff!
I also need to get the blue...
Oh, dang it.
Maybe it's open now.
Oh, come on.
The button room.
You can get it from the top.
I can.
Hold on.
So why would you go up after I leave the platform?
Okay.
Oh, there it is.
It is open.
Look at that.
Would you look at that?
From the button room.
I can make it.
Oh!
Whee!
Let's see.
Is there a secret door?
Am I missing that door?
I feel like so blind in this.
Hmm.
Too used to the convenience of modern game design.
Ah!
I did not mean to press that.
My fingers slipped as I was drinking my tea.
Now we're back.
Oh, I think I need to run off here.
Okay, okay, okay.
I understand.
I understand now.
Maybe from, like, here?
There we go.
Then from there...
Oh, it opens up the door over there!
Ah!
Go back up the stairs.
Oh.
Ah.
Oh, it was timed.
No,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, what the heck?
Why could I do it first time before?
No, no, she got it first tried and never get it again.
There we go.
Now, run.
But don't fall.
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
Yippee!
What did that do?
Wait, maybe that opens for the armor?
Maybe?
Yippee!
Oh.
I'm too good at this game.
Well, we know where it is if we need it, you know.
Okay, blue key, blue door.
Right here.
Okay, finally, back to killing things.
Oh god, why did it have to be you?
Three of them!
This is so unfair.
Oh, ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
I think it's because you're playing literally on...
What?
No, everybody said this was normal!
What are you talking about?
Everybody said this was normal.
63%, 66% secrets.
What did I miss?
Hmm.
What's that?
Is the BFG in this game?
Red key, yellow key.
It is?
Oh, I should save.
Hmm.
Wow, exactly.
Wow, wait.
Oh my goodness.
Ah!
Well, I had exactly enough to be...
To be full health.
He kept us waiting, but you returned to doom, hell.
Rip and tear until it is done.
I hear another guy.
He's snoring.
I hear him.
I don't even stand a chance.
Whoa.
Oh, wait.
Save some of that.
What's wrong with this room?
Oh.
Oh!
Area map!
Yippee!
Today's my birthday!
Wait, who sent that?
Okay!
Happy birthday!
Bye!
Ma-P!
Oh my god, that's a throwback.
Throwback to that time.
I played...
Doom, and I couldn't read.
Oh!
What's this?
I was gonna say, did I go in here?
All these poor little scientists.
All these poor little nerds.
I'm guessing they're scientists.
You know?
Okay, so this is where I...
Yes.
That's what it showed me.
In the...
You!
Yo!
Wait, can I not reopen it?
No!
Blueberry!
Oh my god, more Marines just not as cool as you.
Got it.
No way!
Literally blueballed.
Don't say that.
Shoot the switch.
I wonder if I can redo it.
I
can't remember where I've been.
Oh!
That opened something.
In here?
Nope.
This is where I just came from.
I'm so lost.
I don't remember.
I don't remember at all.
Oh, well.
That's okay.
I don't need the blueberry so much anyway.
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah.
See, it's still activated.
That's okay.
Here's the map.
What was the special map that I got?
What even does it...
What's its purpose?
Ooh!
I want that.
Well, I don't need it right now, but I wouldn't.
Ah!
Switch?
Not a switch.
Uh, maybe a switch.
Punch the switch.
Shoot the switch.
Hmm.
I mean, can't read maps.
It's true!
Um, actually.
Thank you very much.
It's very...
This is the most...
Okay, you can read this?
What does it mean?
There we go.
Flashing lights.
Oh!
Oh my god.
booty wait the exit oh it's right there we need a yellow key
there's so many things we need
okay okay cake scare oh hi oh okay so we need the red key
for both of these then i got it
Oh!
We're right here.
Where we...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Huh?
Wait, what is that showing?
Oh!
Oh, okay.
It's showing that room.
God.
What a tease.
What an actual tease.
I can't go through here yet.
Oh, I can go through here.
That guy is mashing interact on the secret rooms of my
heart.
Yeah.
Oh shoot.
Oh my god.
Where the hell did you come from?
New weapon.
This is the plasma.
a gun, isn't it?
From hell?
Duh.
Duh-been.
Yellow key.
Who is grunting?
All I can hear is grunting everywhere.
Choo!
Oh, you gotta do an early stream for my favorite series.
I just got off work.
Sorry!
Um, wait.
I needed the yellow key.
yellow key in here, right?
That's because it's the weekend.
I tell, you know, I tend to do earlier streams on the
weekend.
It's all...
Okay, yellow.
Is this also yellow?
Nope.
Okay.
Mr. Snoring up in here.
Gosh!
This game is so...
Ah!
This game is So...
Stinky!
Who is snoring?
It's a you?
Have you been snoring this whole time?
Have I been in here?
Uh, this is where I...
Oh, this... wait, yes.
Is stinky a good thing?
Yeah.
It's like a...
You...
When I get my hands on you...
Kind of feeling.
Energy.
Yeah, yeah, that's what I need for the gun.
Kurnari, welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
Losing health like crazy.
Okay, this is where we came from.
Sorry, I'm a bit lost if you couldn't tell.
Oh my god.
I'm strapped!
Maybe I don't need to use the giant whatever's for that guy,
but it's fun to use the rocket launcher.
Why are you grunting?
Over what?
Uh-oh.
We can't go in here.
Can I walk along the walls?
I can.
Nice.
Oh, I could have just literally taken the stairs.
I could have literally taken the stairs, but that's okay.
We have the...
Where haven't we gone?
What's that red...
Red bit?
Right there.
Oh, that's the exit.
Um...
What the?
Oh.
Don't scare me like that!
Doom guy.
Remember Q-R?
Yes, thank you.
Where haven't we gone?
Obviously, past those bars.
Hmm.
Uh.
Showing the blueberry on the map.
So evil.
Whoa.
Goodness.
Take that.
We've pressed that.
Where haven't we been?
Hmm.
Pressing F might help you move, really?
No, I don't think so.
Worth a shot, though.
Maybe I have to go up to those bars?
Hmm.
What was that teleporter over there?
There was a switch, not sure if you shot it already.
Wait, the one that I tried to shoot and it wouldn't let me?
Where was it?
Back through here?
I think.
Can't do this.
Through here?
I got both of these.
What was through here?
Oh yeah, that's right.
It took me to this switch.
Mm-mm-mm.
And then...
The bars and the acid.
Yeah, that's the only thing I can think of to try.
Going to.
Oh!
They open.
Huh!
They're trying to close.
Don't close on my head, please.
Okay.
Don't forget to save.
You're so right.
Oh my gosh, I should totally save right here.
Okay.
Oh.
No.
Oh,
there's a door right here.
Oh!
Are you kidding me?
Oh, my eyes!
My eyes!
It would not be a Doom game if not for just some bullshit
like this.
Oh my god, this...
Ah!
Oh, I could really use a blueberry right now.
Is that everything?
Did something secret elf went up over here?
No?
Okay, let's get out of here.
Oh my god.
Are you guys okay?
Can we see?
Are we still alive?
Oh my god, I can't see anything!
Ow!
God.
Okay, let's just close our eyes until it's gone.
Okay, we're good.
This probably lowered the things...
in here?
Yes.
All according to Kekaku.
Where was the red door?
Where was a red door?
Oh, it was the environmental brightness.
Oh, my bad.
Was it under display?
No, I didn't.
I raised it.
I lowered it.
I didn't raise it that much.
Well, that should be better.
Red door.
Is this what happens when you do the do?
Real doing-to-do footage.
Where was the red door?
There are red switches.
There are.
I'm looking.
Is it that over there?
Is it secret?
No.
Secret?
Actually, I'm not.
I don't know where to go.
Yellow?
In here, I think.
And then in here?
Nope, just kidding.
This way?
This one?
I still can't touch this one.
Oh, this is what I just got.
Okay, this leads back to the green.
In here.
Oh, look.
I don't see any in here.
Hold on.
I'm checking the map.
Where did I miss a switch?
You passed the switches?
I did.
Here?
Why can't I?
I see anything is there any chance of you playing the ROM
hack doom someday it's really good maybe oh I forgot I
forgot that I didn't press those because they were lit up I
thought that I had pressed them how do I get back there oh
shoot Uh, here?
Ah!
Get me in there.
Oh, okay, I just needed to press one of them.
There we go.
25% secrets.
Entering the final outpost.
Oh, my mother.
What a jerk.
Oh.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, my goodness.
Can I shoot some of these guys?
Maybe with a...
you as much as Doom Guy loves oofing his walls.
I can't tell if it's ambiance I'm hearing or wow.
This is kind of... Oh!
Oh, that was close.
Hey!
Where are you?
Oh.
Did I get him?
I can't tell.
I can't tell at all.
okay though.
Okay, saving the game.
Ah!
Oh my god.
There's so many sounds.
Spooky!
Got the chain gun again.
This goes the same way.
Okay, so this is where I just killed all those guys.
Yep, yep, yep.
Saving makes me feel good.
Yeah, I'm a save scumber.
Whatever.
What are these sounds?
I think I got him.
Yep.
Oh.
Sometimes I feel more safe with the...
chain gun and sometimes I feel more safe with the shot, the
shoddy.
They could have limited your saves if they were really
worried about it.
Yeah.
Sometimes, it's so hard to tell if like an older game is
going to be nice to you or not.
You know what I mean?
Sometimes they're just like...
Sometimes they're like...
Yeah, we'll give you like, you know, all this nice stuff And
sometimes they're just evil.
Okay, so we don't have a blue key, so let's keep going.
They gotta make it really hard so that you don't just...
Okay, what's gonna happen here?
Oh!
What I do like about the chain gun is it does kind of stun
them for a second.
So they can't really, like, do much.
What am I hearing?
Is it the spider?
Is it ambiance?
I can't tell it all.
I can't tell it all if it's...
What's going on?
Spooky BGM.
It's really spooky.
Yay!
Uh, oh no!
Uh-oh.
Blue.
Blue water.
Oh!
Nice!
Secret!
The blood made it...
Where am I supposed to go from here?
Actually.
Aha!
Haha!
Hacking?
Actually, he doesn't want to hack this wall.
I don't like the music at all.
It's making me really paranoid.
It's making me super ultra paranoid.
Oh, I'm so scared right now.
Okay, I guess I'll flip this switch.
Oh.
Ah!
Blah!
Oh, my health!
Oh.
I could use a blueberry right now.
Why did my health go down so much when my armor was at max?
It's kind of messed up.
Okay, box of bullets.
There's lots of armor in here, which is nice.
Okay.
They literally phased into existence!
They didn't even come from anywhere!
They didn't even come from behind a wall!
They just...
Ghost men.
Yeah, they lined up for me though, so true.
I hear them.
Oh.
Oh shit.
Oh, I'm gonna run out of bullets at this rate.
Yikes.
Rocket launcher.
Maybe I should have used that.
That's fine, though.
More shotgun shells.
Box of rockets.
Ow!
Shit.
Oh, my God.
Nice.
We're full on rockets.
Um, she's so clutch.
Am I though?
My health.
I need a blueberry stat.
I need a blueberry.
Where was the red door anyway?
Oh, wait, hold on.
you.
Maybe we haven't seen it yet.
I mean, do I'm scared to hold my hand, please?
Okay.
Give me your little quivering baby hand.
It's so small.
I could fit like five of your hands in my hand.
What did that do?
Oh.
There was something timed.
But I'm not quite sure what.
Oh, oh, oh.
I'm not quite sure what that does yet.
Oh, there's red right there.
So do I teleport here?
No.
Oh, it turned berserk.
Look at that.
Will this give me extra health?
No.
Oh, I just can't see.
Whoa, Daniel!
Thank you for the Hakus over on!
I haven't thought too about your trip to Japan wasn't very
good, but here are some funds for the next one.
Hopefully we'll be better.
I missed you a lot.
Ah, thank you.
Thank you so much.
I'm getting deja vu.
I don't know about you.
Gotta wait for that to go back down, right?
Oh, there we go.
Like so.
Okay.
Hmm.
I like how there's, like, more online.
The ambient lighting and everything is pretty fun.
And the music has basically stopped.
Okay, never mind.
It's back.
I'm like, how do I get to the red over there?
Oh yeah, there was this room.
I completely forgot about it.
Bada bada bada bada bada bada bada bada bada bada bada bada.
lie I'm lost again let's see wait
there's a bunch of yellow switches over there did I not
wreck realize did I not see them before or and here oh I
think it's just oh they're just showing me what the
computers are okay you winning dear Probably.
How do I get up there?
There was like a...
I need to get over there.
Because there was a staircase that leads down to the red
room.
Have you played the other dooms before?
I have!
I've played one and two before.
So I'm playing this one before I play three.
It's the Minto guy.
Yeah.
So, teleporter...
Like, I don't think... I can't go through there, right?
Nope.
Oh, and I lost my chance to go through here, too.
There's nothing here?
This blue stuff does hurt me, though, right?
I'm not dumb, right?
Might be a time switch that lets you in with the teleporter.
Oh, three is different and cool, but cool and has great
spooky atmosphere.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, it doesn't hurt me.
Sorry, like I said, it's been a while since I played you
guys, okay?
I can't remember what's good and what's against me, okay?
I just assume everything is like...
Oh, dang.
Wait.
Maybe...
Oh, that must go down.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I just assume everything is against me.
Yay!
Okay.
I figured it out, everybody.
Ugh.
Wait, so is this the Hell Knight or is this the Baron?
I can't remember which one's cooler.
Boo!
Weaker is Hell Knight.
What the?
I have to, like, time it perfectly.
Maybe?
Oh.
Or not.
For now.
We'll leave that alone for now.
Oh!
Is this a trap?
What?
I just got this blueberry, I earned it!
You're not gonna take my health from me!
Oh, shotgun.
Oh my god.
Oh, that was close.
Shoot.
Okay.
What the heck is this?
What the heck was that?
What is all these sounds?
Whoa!
The gun just disappeared.
Oh!
Oh, the gun reappeared.
Supercharge is a blueberry hit with the made magic.
Freaky ghost gun.
Look at all these switches.
First of all, though, I want to go back to...
Here.
And see if this is possible with the right amount of speed.
Wait.
At some point, it goes down, it goes...
The yellow key part is a bit BS.
I really skipped on the reload animation for the super
shotgun.
It's okay.
Okay.
Uh...
That one's gonna go back up though.
It doesn't even move!
Really?
Thanks for the vibe, Gifted!
The solution is on the corridor outside.
Is it now?
I don't mind if you guys give me hints, don't worry about
it.
Just don't tell me the exact answer.
Yellow...
The yellows...
Punch it!
Shoot it!
Wait, so if I go here...
Pop it!
Maybe, uh, what it's pointed at.
The other side?
Huh?
It's the same marking, though.
The fact that there's not even a sound...
It's the most quiet.
Lick it!
It didn't work.
Press E on it.
Oh my god, I thought I had.
I think I hadn't...
when the bars were down.
Thank you.
I'm scared of this room And let's change the
Okay Someone's gonna come down here At some point Was this
the correct one?
I'm not even pressing some of these
You failed, no gun!
What?
What's the method to this madness?
Is there a way to reset it or no?
Ah, so I would have to look at the...
Ah!
I see, I see.
But they only give you two shots, two tries to get it?
That's crazy.
No reset, sadly.
That's okay.
I think I...
That's the plasma gun, right?
I already have it.
Would have been nice to get the ammo for it, though.
One to orient yourself, one to act on it.
That's so...
That's okay.
Alright, we got the blue battery.
Oh my god.
Ouch!
I was changing my gun, you jerk!
I don't even know there were still guys out here.
I thought I blew them all up.
Oh, there's one.
Can I snipe?
Snipe with the shotgun?
Yes, I can.
More!
Oh my god, lots!
Uh-oh.
More rockets, please!
There we go!
Oh!
Whoa!
This game is so exciting.
So many things change and move all the times.
What's that?
Oh, energy cell packs.
Nice.
Don't fall.
Wait.
That was the exit!
88% kills.
88% items.
Who did I miss?
50% secrets.
Entering even simpler.
You cackle as the familiarity of the situation occurs to
you.
the gateway to the demons domain was too accessible you
realize the demons mock you with their invitation it does
not matter the demons spawn like rats and you have the great
AAA UAC poison they crave your bloodthirsty scream shatters
the teleport haze once again you find yourself amidst amidst
Redmist.
So you're saving the game.
Saving the game.
I keep thinking that each level is called Bring It On.
Oh, what the hell is that?
Oh my god!
Oh shoot.
Oh shoot, oh shoot.
Am I even hitting him?
I don't even know.
Ow!
Ooh, got him.
Oh my god.
There's more?
Oh, you.
You bitch.
Please die already.
Die!
Oh my god, there's so many!
Coco Demon!
Die Coco Demon!
Why you have so much health!
Okay.
Yo!
This is where the game gets real.
I can tell.
Nice!
Oh, hello.
Are you stuck in here or...
...
Oh my god, where did you go from?
Oh, there's a blue...
A green berry!
Boxer rockets, nice.
Oh my gosh, I can't see because of the corpse of the Coco
demon.
Yeah, fight each other.
Oh, I thought you were dead.
They just won't stop spawning.
Is this just like one of those maps where I just hold out
and like hope that I don't die?
Can you make chocolate out of a Cocoa Demon?
Yeah.
Probably.
I think it would taste a little bitter.
Oh, blueberry.
Pretty much yes.
Why is it so yellow?
Mm-hmm.
Oh.
There they come.
What was that sound?
Think, think, think, think.
Hmm.
For metal soundtrack to foreboding and beyond.
I know, right?
Like, it's...
The change in atmosphere is actually really crazy.
Holy moly.
Let's see.
So I feel like I can't chat very much because i'm like just
waiting for the next spawn the next wave to what the what
are these what the hell are these oh those are those metal
sounds i was hearing the clink clink clink clink ah okay
okay are they attached to a guy is exit is this chat is this
real Chat!
Is this real?
Yes.
Those deal way more damage than you expect.
I'm glad I avoided it then.
Holy cow.
Oh.
Oh, I should...
Wait.
Go through.
Oh!
Yippee!
Involveability wasted.
I wouldn't have used it.
I wouldn't have been able to use it anyway.
Entering the bleeding.
Ooh, carpet.
Yucky.
The doors are really special, though.
I like what parts when we, like, leave the ship and actually
enter hell.
you know kind of oh chainsaw i got it back i got it back
after all
maybe i'll go to the shoddy shoddy yaddy yaddy
plasma gun oh goodbye
I hear someone.
Trying to like, see if I can snipe them from up here.
But I can snipe.
Save?
Oh, okay.
I'll save.
What the hell?
Swap, swap.
I don't want to go berserker.
Secret item.
Where am I hearing them from though?
I want the upper hand, but I don't think I will have it.
Oh well.
Oh!
PickleBob Hepburn!
That was down though, isn't it just down?
Guess this one's a little bit linear.
Oh, my god.
They were on top of each other, so I didn't even notice him.
Did I kill him?
Yeah.
Oh.
Whoa.
Everything moves in this game.
It's kind of crazy.
Yeah.
Let's get the other one.
This one.
Oh.
Ah, I noticed you.
It does go down.
But when?
Did I miss my opportunity?
Oh, I don't need it.
Okay, but we know it's there.
We know it's there.
Yeah.
Where's all the guys?
Not that I'm complaining.
Oh, well, uh...
There's all the guys.
Devil switch.
Pull my devil trigger.
Hips are so funny.
Lots of pinkies.
Oh, oh, that guy?
Oh, man.
What's a good one?
Um, maybe rocket launch him.
Ow!
Okay.
No!
Oh
my god, where'd you go, Pinky?
There.
Oh.
I got him.
Oh my god, oh there's another one.
And one more.
And another one.
Where is he?
You are not TF2 soldier.
What does that even mean?
I don't even know what that means.
I've never played Team Fortress.
Did I get everybody?
Am I safe to jump down?
Well, I said safe as, you know.
Face rocket tax things.
Why am I just It's just such an idiot, me.
Why do I always take a rocket to the face?
Oh, I hear more.
I think over there, though.
I think I want more shotgun shells.
I'll take the clips, too, though.
Shotgun.
Oh, okay.
That's here.
Oh!
Look at this trap.
If this was never a trap to be...
If this was a trap of...
If I've never seen a trap before, I would still know that
this is a trap.
Is there anything else?
I'm trying to look for any...
Oh.
Oh, there's this room.
The blueberry.
Oh, I hear them.
I hear them growling.
Where are you guys?
Ah!
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god.
Yo, that's so unfair.
Ah!
That's so unfair.
Okay, all right.
I gotta stop being a little baby.
All my homies hate lost souls.
Hell yeah.
What is that key?
Hello?
Can you stop?
Can you, like, stop roaring and...
I think it was those guys, right?
There's a few more.
I thought we had peace and quiet.
Oh my god, you guys are so...
Annoying.
Oh.
Oh, it's the pinkies.
And there's a pinkie.
Okay, we need the yellow key.
Cool.
Easy.
I really want the blueberry.
Should I risk it for the biscuit?
No peace and quiet, only busting.
You're so right.
Look at these.
At the place, when I went to, my sister got married last
year.
And when I went to her wedding, the place that she got
married at had, like, all these, like, little demon gremlin
statues that look like this.
Hell is so inserious.
Risk it for the biscuit.
Yeah, yeah.
What's gonna come out, I wonder?
We'll do the chain gun.
What?
I'm so glad I risked it for the biscuit.
Yippee!
Now they're messing with you.
I know, right?
Oh!
I didn't conceal this armor before either.
Nice.
Wait, am I full on a shotgun?
Seriously?
Wow.
Okay, uh, it was up here, and around the corner, and through
here, yellow.
What's that gun over there?
I don't think I've picked that one up yet.
Come here, Pancake!
Can't believe Min's sister married Vlad Dracula.
Oh wait, I can touch this, can I?
This is just water.
I'm stronger than you.
What is this?
Oh!
Ah!
Am I moving with the water?
Oh, I am.
That was pretty nice.
Is he gonna talk to me?
Eventually he will be able to get me.
No secret behind the water.
What kind of game is this?
Atlantis no Nazo statues on the floor.
Hold up.
Press that.
Where does this go to?
Oh, back at the top.
Okay.
Where's the... where's the armpit?
Oh, okay.
What did that do?
Oh, I thought it said a box of spells for a second.
I was like, wow, wait.
Wow, we got the...
Oh, I got the BFG.
I didn't mean to shoot it twice, but I guess that worked.
Wait, which one is that?
Seven?
Seven.
baby okay well we pressed um the one over here so let's go
back and see what has changed what is going to try and kill
me now out here
i'll check from up above wait okay i'm waiting for those
damn spiders as soon as i hear that
You don't, you're not as, you're not as nice.
Big freaky gun.
What does BFG stand for?
Bust him feels good.
Yeah.
Wait, where, what did that change at all now?
I pressed the switch.
And, um...
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
I could plasma him.
Hey, what a way!
Stop my arm- my ammo.
Just stay right there.
Yamp!
Where are all you guys come from?
Shubha Shubha!
In my head they're saying Shubha Shubha.
Bustin feels good.
Makes me feel good.
It feels good.
I wanted him to get nice and close.
The exit!
Wait.
But have I gotten every guy in here?
I want to make sure I've killed everything.
No demons left behind.
Is this a secret?
I hear nothing alive, but sometimes there's sneak.
you know sometimes you can't hear them until you're right up
on them but it's true i don't hear anything else i do not
hear any other noises
oh that's health okay guess i'll leave
watch it say 95 oh yuppie 96% time.
42% secret.
Terrorcore!
Ooh.
Thank you.
Let's save the game.
Level 11.
Wait, how many did you guys say there was?
30?
Maybe I'll stop at 15.
I'm feeling okay, but...
What was that?
Ooh.
Oh, there's thunder now and everything.
Scary.
Are you behind here?
Oh, blue key.
Yeah, because I totally want to go in there.
They're making it really enticing, you know?
They're making it really enticing to want to go in there.
I hear a lot going on.
It's just, yeah.
The compilation of you playing Doom was my original intro to
you.
So it's nice seeing you back after all this time.
Looking forward to starting MDS 2.
It's my favorite.
Yippee!
Oh my gosh, so long ago.
Ah!
Thank you!
Thanks for sticking around all this time.
Who's in here?
Oh.
Two little Cthulhu's turned off.
Oh, oh, oh, uh, uh, oh, okay, never mind, I think it raises
and, oh, okay, it'll fall eventually, there we go, yippee,
25 regular levels, four secret levels, and three fun levels,
that can only be accessed through the passwords, oh, thank
you, thank you, thank Thank you.
Hello!
I hear them, but they don't...
They're too afraid of me.
Bloogie!
It's me.
Actually, I'm afraid of them.
Oh!
It's so wet!
Why?
Why is it so wet?
Squishy.
Oh,
almost had them.
Got them.
Dummies!
I am getting them, right?
Yeah.
Two slime for demons.
Ghost brain higher than demon brain.
Actually, is that...
I'm afraid.
I'm afraid of the splash damage.
I think I got one guy down.
Come here.
No, I did not...
Oh, there was one guy down.
I don't want to keep using my shotgun shells because I was
running low.
But there's a box right here.
I say low.
I said like 50s.
But I used two at a time.
So it's like...
There we go.
I pressed a demon button.
It does a whole lot of demon nothing.
You can switch to the normal shotgun by pressing 3 again.
Oh, really?
Oh, this goes down.
Hello?
Oh.
Just gonna.
Come on.
Aim.
I don't feel like dealing with you.
Should I ever get a shot?
consider playing my house dot well I know my house it's my
little mob with lots of doom cute also please don't make fun
of my name my parents don't like me well I was I was I
wasn't gonna make fun of it I until you said something I'm
not gonna make fun of you until you tell me not to make fun
in you.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, gosh.
I'm so glad I can see these guys.
Where's the other one?
Where are you?
Oh.
I think I got him.
Armor.
What if we ask you to make fun of us?
What then?
Um, then it's no fun.
I like, I mean, I don't It's gotta be like a balance, right?
What does that sound?
Okay, I will come back here.
Eventually.
Probably.
I have not gone to this side.
Oh.
Wait, I'm guessing.
Okay, run!
I would hate it if you made fun of me.
Totally.
Oh, I don't even need this.
I'm such an idiot.
Red key.
This is where we came from.
Yes.
Where do I go?
Got Nigel.
I'm full on rockets.
I'm full on a lot of stuff.
Actually, the most I think I need is shotgun shells, but I'm
not low.
Hmm.
I would totally hate it.
Why would you, you guys then will use it against me.
If I make fun of you, you'll be like, she hates us.
If I make fun of you, then you'll be like, she really hates
us.
You'd be so sad.
Just pressing everything that I can.
Just roofing every wall that's possible.
Prove that you don't hate us, then.
How can I prove that?
Oh.
Oh, I found...
I found a blueberry.
What do you want me to do to...
To prove this to you?
I'll show you.
You son of a...
I think I got him.
Yeah.
Loser.
Oh, there's a key over there.
Yo, they were cheating.
They were!
Yellow key.
Okay.
Will this lower that key for me?
No.
What's this go?
Oh!
Look at that.
Nice.
Um.
Can I shoot this?
Oh.
Nope.
Just like Doom 2.
This game is so evil.
I know you don't hate us.
Really?
I'm not doing my job well enough there.
I need to try harder.
Where was that in here?
Here.
Was there anything else here?
I think I hear another one probably on the other side.
Oh yeah, because there's a blueberry here.
How do I...
Hmm.
How do I get this blueberry?
Let's try the other side.
Oh, wait.
Where the hell am I?
Hmm.
Oh, here?
Um.
How do I get to it?
Can't wait for you to go on your hater training arc.
I'm a hater.
That's me.
Where?
Do I go this car?
Where do I go?
I'm gonna keep the chain gun up.
Well, okay, we got the yellow key.
That's all we need for now.
It's okay if I can't get to it.
Which yellow door was...
This is red door.
Yellow door.
Oh, this map.
Raiders.
Hello!
Thank you for the raid!
Raid back thanks for the gifted.
Who raided me?
Hello!
Thank you!
I'm playing Doom.
Doom.
um doom 64 from the nintendo 64.
maybe i'm hearing this
where was the other yellow door though guys i'm so lost
vijay thanks for the gifted
is is that it i'm so lost i'm so lost i don't know where to
go
Oh, red door.
Oh, that scared me.
Up, I think.
I'm trying to see...
Okay, I'm just going to follow a map.
We know that we've killed most of the guys in this area,
so...
Why is this map so...
You know?
Why?
Okay, let's queue.
Let's queue out.
Where am I supposed to go?
Oh!
Ducky, thank you for the gift!
Simba, welcome back!
You hate us, so you think about us, right?
Oh, that's the logic we're using.
Upstairs in those catwalks.
Okay.
So up in here.
Up in here?
No, I pressed that.
Oh, this is where I said I needed the yellow key.
Kakiman!
Ew.
Ew, nasty.
Oh.
It's kind of fun.
How do I get over there?
Hmm.
How do I get to that spot?
Okay.
Oh, I've been here.
Or I've killed here.
Maybe I haven't been here, but I have killed.
I
have unleashed...
I hate pain and elemental so much.
I hate those guys so much.
Is there anything over here?
There's so many little areas that look like they could hold
secrets.
I hear another one.
Unless that's a...
Pickle.
Hmm.
Okay.
Now we have the red key so we can go all the way back.
All the way back.
This direction?
What is that?
Was that just doors closing?
Be on your lookout, everybody.
Be on a lookout for...
Okay.
Wait, no, I need to go downstairs.
Oh, there he is!
Gosh.
I won't be able to watch live because I'm working overtime!
Oh no!
But I'm super excited to see you work your way through the
Outer Wild DLC and the bots.
Good luck and have fun!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Yeah, um, oh.
Oh, this is where they killed these guys.
At Afkai, Atara and I were actually visited by one of the
devs.
Oh, oh my gosh.
Oh, oh, come on.
Where'd you go?
And he was just...
And he wrote me a note.
He was like, by the way, you know, there's still the DLC for
Outer Wilders.
if you ever play it.
Yeah, Jeffrey!
How do you guys know?
He loves VTubers.
He's so nice.
Zero items.
Zero secrets.
Oof.
Alter, okay.
So I was just like, you know what?
Yeah, you're right, Jeffrey.
I gotta do the DLC.
So...
Yeah, and then I was just like, why not?
Why not?
Why don't I just do it?
What's stopping me?
Nothing's stopping me.
Myself, I'm stopping me.
There's a secret exit here.
Can you find it?
There is.
Is it in the tree?
Sounds like cats meowing.
Oh!
Hold on.
Let me make sure that pause is okay.
Pause!
Give me one second, guys.
She did want out.
notice.
Oh, I feel so bad.
She wanted out.
And I didn't notice she probably wanted to go, like, eat or
go to the bathroom.
Don't forget to save.
Oh, thank you.
Oh.
Sorry if you can hear my crunch.
Is this water that will kill me?
No, it's not.
It's just dirty, poopy water.
nasty
oh god she ate pies oh i
see you up there oh my god
my health my health my health you stupid
Oh, it's that guy.
No wonder.
I wonder if I can take him down.
Hold on.
No spamming, please.
Thank you.
May I offer you a blueberry?
in this trying time.
Yes, please.
I can't tell if I'm getting it or not.
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
Oh,
yeah.
Die already.
Just die already!
Oh.
Dang it.
Wasting rockets.
Die already.
Why can't I aim at you anymore?
Finally!
Good molly!
Oh, I got health.
Oh my gosh, I haven't had to collect regular health in so
long.
Dodge, dip, duck
This map is This is like It feels kind of Castlevania It's
kind of funny Blueberry Probably shouldn't Just press random
buttons But you know Wow, red berry!
What's that one do?
I don't think I've ever seen the red berry before.
This map is bonkers.
I'm already so lost.
I went through...
I guess I should drop down and kind of look around somewhere
else, but...
Like, uh, over here.
Whoa!
Wow!
This is so...
So cool!
Oh.
Take that.
Apparently there was a secret exit at the beginning, but I
just chose to ignore it.
Red bear equals partial invisibility.
Ah, okay, okay.
Tree.
At least the trees aren't here to kill me.
I love this little cave.
It's so cool.
Cool.
Oh.
Should have known something would be in there.
And I did.
I did know.
Cozy cave.
The demons got it made.
They've got such a cool little thing going on here.
Oh, but there's nothing extra special over here.
I don't...
Oh my god.
Oh, that was close.
Oh, this is actually a door!
Health bonus.
All the ambient lighting is so fun.
You're a gamer.
Nice dodges.
Thank you.
Oh, look at that.
Oh.
Plasma gun.
Uh-oh.
What am I pressing?
I'm scared.
What am I...
What am I inviting into the open, you know?
Box a bullet.
I'll take it.
End.
Oh, that's nothing.
That's just some pile of meat.
The music is so scary.
I'm not gonna lie.
really don't like it actually like i like it like it's
spooky and that's why i like it but i don't like it kind of
scared i'm kind of scared you guys oh it's unsettling yeah
like the the meowing is really uh i don't i don't like it
where why is there demon meat on the ground I wonder.
Sounds like a baby crying.
Yeah, that's what I mean by the cat noises.
I guess...
What?
There's an exit over there.
Is that where the exit is?
Okay, good to know.
Good to know.
That's where we go.
What did those switches do?
I don't know.
Oh, this game is such a mystery.
Morning.
Can I run to this?
Oh, I can!
Go.
Ah!
This area.
Yeah, yeah.
Shut up.
Oh!
We got a red key!
I'm hearing something.
Oh!
I got him.
All right.
Red key.
Where?
Ah!
Yeah!
Imp.
Come back here, Imp.
And there's...
Oh.
There's a pinky down there.
Somewhere.
What?
Thank you for the red!
Oh, sorry.
I can... Why did YouTube change it to white text, man?
Don't understand.
Oh, we got the invisibility.
Nice.
Um...
I, uh...
Rose went and sampled a cat.
Oh my god!
I was invisible!
How did you find me?
This is messed up.
Messed up.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
I'm going to go down here.
Grab some more shotgun shells.
And then get the pinky here.
There he goes.
Oh, this is the...
Isn't this the beginning?
Yeah.
Yeah, this is the beginning.
This is where we teleported away.
We didn't go anywhere, like, over here.
Jay, thanks for the vibe, gifted.
Oh, wait.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Oh, someone else is shooting at me from somewhere.
Not quite sure where.
Blueberry.
Where are they shooting?
Oh.
Don't walk away.
He was like, I'm not even going to look.
I know they're going to hit you.
I don't even need to see.
Come back and fight me.
Like a man.
Hola, mint.
Hola.
two spooky months i know i was just thinking that i was like
wow i can't believe it's been like two months since i've
since i've come back to streaming already feels so much
longer and shorter at the same time right it's partial
invisibility like being partially pregnant
what i don't think you can be partial I don't even think you
can be impartial.
I don't think so.
Oh my god, the cross.
Spooky.
We're almost out of year, baby.
How do I get...
Wait.
Okay.
So we got the red key.
So where was a red door?
I don't remember.
Let's teleport back.
up here and figure it out I said oh hey you don't run away
yeah that's right
can't believe it's been two years boys oh here
oh I'm lost in the sauce
Oh my god.
Holy cow.
Just came up and I don't even know he was going to be there.
Nice.
Anybody in there?
Plasma gun?
Plasma ammo?
Oh, sacrifice.
Ooh.
This seems like kind of a big deal.
Oh!
What is this?
Wait, I got unholy firepower.
Wait, what is this?
I thought it was a...
Like a human body!
Does this use my health?
What does this...
The unmaker.
Ow!
I obliterated him!
It unmakes things.
What does it use for ammo?
Really?
powerful energy weapon let's go um how do i get up there
let's see oh my gosh the baron scared me
you're here maybe
uh ah got it okay yellow skull yellow Yellow door, yellow
door doko, yellow door, um, oh boy, tei nai, whoop!
I got a, I got a berry, blueberry.
Wait, so what number is that?
Okay, it's eight, oh my gosh.
Holy cow.
Okay, yellow door, yellow door.
Is it friendly fire of ghosts fight demons like this?
No, we're completely different, ghosts and demons.
Ghosts are way superior, obviously.
Yellow door.
Do you guys remember?
So close yet so far from the secret exit.
It's okay, don't worry.
That's why it's a secret.
If I don't get it, I don't get it.
Sometimes I do.
Sometimes I have a stroke of genius.
Maybe, okay.
How do I get to there?
Let's go back this way.
Let's teleport back up because I do maybe want to try
through that exit.
And sometimes just a stroke.
Yeah?
Love when I have just a stroke.
Okay maybe I go through here.
So yellow.
Oh!
Of course it's so yellow in here.
8.
I want to use it on you.
Oh, it misses very easily, though.
It misses extremely easily.
Yeah, unbirthed him.
Happy unbirthday to you, Baron.
Is this timed?
It's just so funny that they were like, nope, you can't get
it unless you kill that guy.
And it was like...
If you sneak up behind her...
Oh, I missed someone.
I wonder who.
Zero secret.
Wow!
I love M64.
Thanks for the super chat.
Baby mode moment?
I guess so.
Wow!
I love that thing right there!
Woo!
The decor is immaculate.
Are we on what?
13 now?
Oh.
Come here!
The sound is on, it's really echoey.
Hmm.
Ooh.
Oh, lots of...
Lots of...
Oh, oh, oh, I hear those things again.
Oh, oh, oh, I hear the clanks.
I heard it, I heard it, I heard it.
Hmm.
Uh oh, what am I gonna have a...
Am I in for a bad time?
Am I in for it?
I'm afraid of them.
I don't know where they come from.
I don't think I really need to even go in here though,
right?
We'll just, uh...
Cruising for our bruising.
Oh!
Ow!
I thought I dodged that!
Wait, where did it come from?
oh my gosh oh okay well
shoot check out immorifer's doom 64 discord server oh i
don't know if i'll join that but if anybody is interested
and wants to join more doom stuff then they can do that but
thank you
not yet oh red key.
Uh, in here?
Why can't I pick this up?
Ah!
Oh my god, Ouch, Ouch, Ouch, Ouch, Ouch.
Oh my god.
guy that was so close.
I almost just died.
I almost just fell in.
Oh.
I didn't even see that guy over there.
What the?
Can you teabag in this game?
Can't even jump.
I don't think you can teabag.
Wasted opportunity, truly.
I guess we'll save that for later.
And any other pillars that have any pushy buttons?
Any demon buttons?
Greetings from Chile!
Also, first time watching.
Hello!
Thanks for watching!
Thanks for joining.
We're having a doontastic day.
I hope you are as well.
Where?
Do that little...
You heard the...
I heard the clanks.
Okay, I'm just gonna go.
Yeah, I didn't even...
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
And it doesn't lift this up.
But maybe it lifts up the other one.
Woo!
There we go.
Oh, oh, no.
Oh, wait, no, it didn't.
It didn't do at all what I thought it would.
What the heck?
You guys are so funny.
Oh my god, I thought that was a person standing there.
Oh, that freaked me out for a second.
Wait, where the hell am I?
Oh shoot.
Okay, there's a lot going on in here.
There's...
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
There's a lot going on here.
Make it easy.
Shoot and dodge.
Shoot and punch.
Where are you?
Shuten Doji.
I mean, I wish.
I wish.
She's...
I don't know much about fate, but I know Shuten Doji.
I think I saw another one.
Well, I know.
There.
Where are you?
Oh.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Where?
Oh!
Oh my gosh, there's still so many.
Okay, one more.
One more.
I could save him for later, but...
I like to clean up an area, you know.
Mint and shoot and doji out of a win?
Oh my gosh, so embarrassing!
I'm too shy.
Okay, screw it.
I don't care.
I'll come back.
I'll get them when we get there.
Wait.
Which is right now.
Apparently.
Wait, there's more?
Oh.
Where else are they coming from?
I'm too shy for that outfit, you guys.
Green berry.
Oh no, how do I get to him?
Ask and you shall receive.
May I have a berry?
May I have a bite?
This one's kind of spooky looking.
Shooting has a made outfit of her own?
She does!
Why have I never seen this before?
Or maybe I haven't.
I just forgot.
Red key.
Okay, good.
Oh, oh, wait.
We don't have the blue key.
Yeah.
I just noticed all the little gargoyles are staring at me.
How?
Why are you guys so obsessed with me?
Stop looking.
Let's see.
Is there anything?
I'm looking for any buttons to push that aren't my own.
This game do be pushing my buttons, though.
Wait, can I go back?
Oh.
Okay, I can go back up.
La la la la.
Whoa!
It just came from the wall!
Oh, it's here.
Should we try for it?
I might die.
Here, I'm gonna save.
Save game.
Okay.
Make sure...
Oh.
Run is on.
Ha!
Yippee!
Um, I don't think I remember...
Okay, this is the beginning.
I don't remember pushing any buttons, but...
And we don't have the red key yet.
No, okay, so that's still not open.
Okay.
In here...
Again.
No.
Yes.
Yeah.
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Stop it!
Wait, where was it again?
Wait, now I'm lost actually.
Okay, hold on.
Don't shoot at me.
This is the entrance.
Oh, here we go.
Okay.
So we didn't go this way.
I could probably get the green berry from here.
Let me get the green berry.
Invulnerability!
And let's hurry.
Are you dooming?
I can't see anything actually.
Oh god.
I'm dooming!
But I can't- oh gosh, I can't see anything while I'm
dooming.
Oh god,
oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god.
Oh.
Let's do this.
Yeah!
Everybody okay?
Everybody good?
Un-make those barons.
Ah!
Uh-oh.
When does it end?
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Um, kind of a beat.
Indiana Jones time.
I sure hope I didn't miss something.
Probably did, but...
Oh, my throat is really starting to hurt.
Okay, so I do need to go out here.
Got it.
Let's try again.
Ow!
I took minimal damage.
Tomb of 64 is some of the most deadly traps since Plutonia.
Not Plutonia.
Blue key acquired.
Why do I get out of here?
Exit?
Exit, where
the heck is the exit?
Unless I...
I have to...
Is it only open?
Nope, oh shit.
I'll take darts over chain gunners and archmiles.
Maybe.
Hug the wall.
Okay.
La la la.
Oh!
It was here the whole time.
That's so funny.
Maybe I should have used the berry for that moment.
I don't live, but I do learn.
Alright, so now we got the blue key.
Blue was...
I might have to make this my last level, though, because...
My throat is really killing me.
My throat is killing me.
And I...
I must confess.
I'm still sicky.
Still sicky.
Okay.
Very cool.
Oh.
You're eating through this game?
I think it's because I chose an easier level.
Which I thought was normal.
I really thought it was normal.
I didn't want to play on easy mode.
Where am I hearing?
Pinky.
Right there.
Are you finishing in one?
stream no no no i have it on my schedule for finishing um
next sunday same time i think i think i have put it at the
same time i can't remember actually but um i hate these
things but uh i i could have if i was feeling better i would
play it in one stream oh wait a second
Oh!
Wait.
I thought I was feeling better though.
Holy cow.
Ow!
He was camping me for real.
The libraries.
Oh.
Oh my goodness.
I'll unalive you though.
Unbirth you?
What was it?
Oh, that was close.
We're in the library.
I love the decor.
I love these tall, like, nosferatu-looking goofy guys here.
And they're everywhere.
Ow!
Oh, it was unbirth.
Oh, okay.
Unbirth you!
Another little maze going on in here.
Oh!
Never mind.
Brow.
Oh, it's unmake!
Everyone's giving me wrong information!
Well you guys kept saying I'm birthed, I'm birthed I was
like, oh It must be that one
Ew, I'm hearing something
Unless it's just the ambience
You didn't pin the new schedule on Twitter Yes, I know, I
know I haven't posted it on Twitter yet because I...
I, uh...
Oh, oops!
I, um...
I was trying to...
I tried to spread out my tweets a little bit.
I don't know if you've noticed, but like...
If I'm just like, oh, I have to tweet about...
Like my waiting room or something, then I'll hold off on
posting something else.
Oh!
Choo!
Thank you!
Do you even know what unbirth means?
No?
Wait.
Wait, no I don't.
What does it mean?
I thought it was like, I think of, whenever I think of
unbirthing, I think of Alice in Wonderland, they say a very
merry unbirthday.
So I just think of it as that.
Don't look it out.
Okay.
You guys scare me sometimes.
Oh.
Red key.
Yeah, they go, a very merry on birthday to...
A very merry on birthday to me.
To me.
A very merry on birthday to you.
Oh shoot.
I hear him.
Oh!
He's right here.
Were you here the whole time?
You're supposed to turn around.
You're supposed to...
Stop circling.
You're ruining my plan.
It's a fetish term.
Think of it as like a reverse of birth.
A very merry unbirthing to you two minutes.
Stop!
Now I know what it means!
I think!
I actually don't know what it means though.
So do you pretend like...
Do you pretend to be like the placenta?
And stuff?
I wonder.
How do I get...
Oh, here.
Alright, red door was...
I mean, we were all there once.
Some people just want to return to...
To baby.
Where was a red door?
Or was it a red switch?
I can't ever...
Oh!
Red door!
This looks like a boss area.
Ow!
Okay.
There we go.
Is that it?
Was it just that guy?
And some fire in the middle?
Uh-oh.
Wait, I didn't mean to pick this one.
Let's pick the unmaker.
I'll remember its name from now on.
I'm sorry.
The design of this room is awesome, right?
It's so cool.
Boxer rocket.
Short gun.
Did I grab everything?
I can't.
My health is...
Okay.
Cool.
Okay, mister.
They locked you in there for a reason, I think.
Nobody likes you.
Nobody invited you.
Yippee!
That was 100% our fault.
Yeah, it was.
There's an indie game called The Citadel.
Oh, yes, I do know The Citadel.
It's classic Doom with hot anime girls.
I do know it, actually.
Unbirthing one word Shlorp I'm sorry I don't know what's
going on 100% kill 72% item Zero secret So sad The eye of
the storm I know that I said that was my last game I just
want to take that guy out while he's not paying attention
Okay Okie dokie I think I am going to finish here, though,
and then we'll finish next week.
Mint knows the Citadel-based.
Citadel is also cursed in a way I never expected.
Really?
I've only heard of it.
I don't know much about it.
But Iron Lung has the same musical composer.
Is this game?
Maybe that's why all the ambiance is really good.
Oh, gosh.
My nose is so itchy right now.
I hate it being sick.
I hate that my throat is hurting all the time.
I hate that I'm still not recovered.
Good wiping today, ghosty.
Hope you're feeling better soon.
Thank you.
It's 4 a.m.
Can I finally go to bed?
Yes, Android.
Go to bed.
Of course you would be here for Doom.
Tomorrow I'll be doing DLC of...
I decided to do, rather than like splitting it up like one
part, one week, and one part the next week, since I, it's, I
played Outer Wilds somewhat recently, and so the
information's still kind of fresh in my brain, but I want to
play, I wanted to play while it's still fresh in my, in my
head.
So yeah, thanks for the stream.
Thank you guys, thanks.
are hanging out thanks for returning to doom mint my podcast
merch just arrived it's so good thank you doomed fireman
thank you berlin glad you're having fun with doom 64 i know
that you will love doom 3 when you get around to it i'll be
feeling better soon thank you oh my gosh yeah doom 3 and
then i do like i said i do want to play like doom eternal i
want to get to the the new doom really inspired me so i'm
like but i'm not a doom player unless i play all the dooms
if you're planning on revisiting doom or doom 2 will you be
willing to play them on brutal doom or even project
brutality hmm hmm I'll think about it I think I need to get
a bit better before I up my level too much though you're a
doomer name all the doom games I'm a doom I'm a doomer I'm a
I'm a boomer oh my god I wonder if I still have that I used
to have um uh the doom logo but it said boomer instead of
doomer
I wonder I should still have it I don't think why I would
delete it Sorry if you can hear me crunching.
Oh, I do still have it!
Ta-da!
Me!
Boomer.
Ah.
Can we call you the what guy?
The phantom guy.
Yeah, perfect.
Boomer.
Boomer eternally.
Aren't we all boomers at this point?
Well, get it, because I'm a boomer.
Get it?
Because I say boo.
Because I'm a ghost.
I'm not a boomer, like you guys.
I'm a boomer.
Today you are the baby mode boomer.
Stop judging my baby mode.
I really thought...
I really truly thought that I was playing on normal.
Okay, I'm still having fun with it.
Ha ha ha, unsubbed.
Stop!
You still need to play the 62 Doom games.
Between 2 and 64.
Oh boy.
Uh, yup.
I guess I'm a Doom YouTuber now.
I'm a Doom YouTuber now.
Drop welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Okay, I would stick around and talk more, but my throat is
really starting to hurt.
I think I am going to call it here.
I hope you guys had a good weekend.
And, um, sorry that I couldn't stream this yesterday, but,
uh, glad that I could stream it today.
I've got a full, full week ahead of us.
So, um, lots of stuff.
Aren't there 61 games between 2 and 64?
I'm not a scientist.
Coyote Actual, welcome back for two months.
Thank you.
Hmm.
But hopefully, um, I'll be feeling better this week.
week and all that fun stuff so i'll i'll rest lots i will
i'll rest lots so that i can feel better and um have lots of
fun with all my streams this week yubi minto i got some good
news and some bad news bad news i broke my wrist oh no good
news i get to watch you live more often yubi are you okay no
mr mcmay oh i hope you feel better too Hmm.
Let's have a good week.
This week, everybody.
Yay!
Thank you, Minto.
No, thank you.
Otsu Minto, Otsubustin, Otsu Boomer, Otsu Doomer.
And I'll see you guys tomorrow for Outer Wilds.
Echoes, Echoes of the Eye.
Eye of the Echoes.
Echoes of the Eye.
Echo, uh, I can't remember where the name.
Otsu Minto, Otsu Bustin.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'm gonna go rest my throat now.
It's like right, it's like not my throat.
It's like the back of my mouth.
It hurts so bad.
Okay, bye bye.
Thanks for watching you guys.
Thanks for hanging out.
Bye bye.
Thank you for the super chat.
Toe base, I hope you had a good day.
Heart base, post today.
Oh, I'm so sorry.